hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
la movilización de migrantes venezolanos
hacia otros países continúa pese a los
bloqueos por el kobe 19 miles de
personas buscan quedarse en colombia
pero otras familias siguen su camino
hacia países del sur del continente en
ese tránsito y ante el temor de que el
virus se propague hacia sus territorios
los gobiernos de ecuador y perú
reforzaron sus fronteras con tropas y
artillería una medida criticada por
organizaciones de derechos humanos que
cuestionen el uso de efectivos militares
para la gobernanza de sus fronteras en
un contexto donde se registra el
tránsito de venezolanos en busca de
protección ante las medidas tomadas para
restringir la movilidad los migrantes se
ven obligados a cruzar por pasos no
oficiales e incluso controlados por
mafias lo que empeora aún más las ya
críticas condiciones del tránsito esto
es lo que pasa en las fronteras
estas imágenes vuelven a registrarse en
las vías de colombia ecuador y perú
grupos de venezolanos caminan kilómetros
lejos de su país en busca de un trabajo
comida y un futuro mejor para sus hijos
pero ahora las fronteras fueron
militarizadas para contener el tránsito
y esperamos que
para trabajar en este punto limítrofe
entre colombia y ecuador varios esperan
que se disuelva este retén militar para
seguir su viaje por vías seguras y es
que los cierres estrictos de fronteras
por la pandemia desviaron la migración
hacia las trochas y otros pasos
irregulares agudizando más la crítica
situación humanitaria de los que huyen
para allá basta ya uno andas en una
lucha uno antes caminando no quiere un
bienestar para la familia uno quiere
seguir pero uno no no se puede porque no
basta ya basta ya basta hasta cuándo
vamos a seguir así los gobiernos aducen
que la migración plantea un problema
sanitario para los países que buscan
detener los contagios de kobe 19 en sus
territorios así ecuador y perú
justifican el recurso de los militares
para controlar los pasos como verificado
también que se han destruido varios
pasos ilegales y continuamos por
supuesto patrullando toda nuestra
frontera para garantizar de que esto no
ocurra la decisión de desplegar
militares en la frontera se da después
de que la policía peruana informará
sobre la detención de al menos
inmigrantes que intentaron supuestamente
ingresar al país de forma irregular
tras el envío de militares a las zonas
de frontera hubo denuncias sobre los
disparos al aire que habría lanzado un
uniformado peruano para disuadir a los
caminantes un hecho que pone en tela de
juicio la capacidad de dichas fuerzas
del orden para atender una crisis de
trasfondo humanitario
previamente hablamos con marina navarro
directora ejecutiva de amnistía
internacional en perú a quien le
preguntamos sobre si están los
uniformados preparados para detener el
tránsito de personas que buscan
movilizarse por las regiones y cuáles
son los riesgos para ellos ante tal
despliegue en la amnistía internacional
estamos realmente preocupados por la
militarización que estamos viendo en la
frontera entre ecuador y perú porque los
militares no están preparados para el
control migratorio no tienen las
herramientas no tienen la capacitación
para poder hacer un control migratorio
entonces podemos ver imágenes como las
que ocurrieron la semana pasada en la
cual militares incluso en presencia de
niños de muy corta edad dispararon al
aire y puedes llegar a ver situaciones
realmente en la que se podrían llegar a
ver
atentar contra los derechos humanos de
estas personas que recordemos que son
extremadamente vulnerables muchos
menores de edad mujeres gestantes
personas mayores que están ahí paradas
en la frontera entre ecuador y perú
y además le consultamos sobre cuál
debería ser la estrategia regional para
atender a los migrantes venezolanos
cuando los gobiernos de los países
receptores sostienen que una potencial
propagación del cou y 19 les plantea un
problema adicional cuando las personas
están huyendo porque tienen miedo por su
vida porque realmente ya están en una
situación en la que no pueden aguantar
van a no ver de todas maneras entonces
es mucho mejor que esto se haga de una
forma irregular controlada tal vez se
deberían de buscar estos espacios donde
se puede hacer ayuda humanitaria donde
se puede hacer el control también de la
pandemia pero que al mismo tiempo se
respete el derecho de las personas a
solicitar refugio pongamos el ejemplo de
perú pero lleva desde el mes de
septiembre y solo lo reabrió por por
tres meses sin que se puedan hacer
solicitudes de refugio ni en fronteras
ni por ni a nivel digital ni en el
territorio peruano entonces qué ocurre
con todas estas personas que huyen de
violaciones masivas de derechos humanos
y que quieren solicitar refugio es lo
que se tiene que hacer es hacer una
manera regular de una manera controlada
bueno para absolutamente todos para las
personas que vienen solicitando refugio
y también para la salud pública de todos
nuestros países que estamos
efectivamente en una situación de
pandemia
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
se estima que durante el primer semestre
de 2021 habrá un mayor flujo migratorio
de venezolanos causado por la crisis
económica política y humanitaria en su
país y el dato de migración de la semana
3000 millones de dólares es la cifra que
necesita la organización internacional
para las migraciones para atender
durante 2021 las necesidades de al menos
50 millones de personas desplazadas cuya
situación empeoró por la pandemia de
kobe 19
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan conectados con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]